this is the image Saudi Arabia wants the
world to see women driving for the first
time even boxing a kingdom trying to
rehabilitate its international
reputation with sport the vehicle of
choice and now they're on the brink of
claiming the ultimate States a symbol
ownership of a Premier League football
club but it's this image that they can't
escape
Saudi dissident and journalist Jamal
khashoggi entering their consulate in
Istanbul for the final time once inside
he was brutally murdered
now his fiance through her lawyers is
urging the Premier League to block the
sale of Newcastle United to Saudi Arabia
I know her TJ has said that she thinks
that this takeover if it does go ahead
would make the Premier League complicit
in Jamal's murder why did she feel so
moved to to intervene to all the very
serious allegations and accusations that
have been leveled against I'm stood
outside the premier league headquarters
nobody's here at the moment nor of the
keshavjee family received any response
to their pleas but everything is
pointing towards this deal being
completed in the coming days
[Applause]
but in Newcastle talk of sports washing
is a clipped by desperation to get rid
of the current owner Mike Ashley they
blame the sports direct billionaire for
years of mismanagement and are prepared
to dance with a different devil I know
the Saudis have a bad reputation but I
don't I don't think I should bear have
any bearing again on the takeover of
Newcastle because we're desperate to get
rid of the person who's in charge
everybody's got their own opinion on
human rights and I feel sorry for the
laughs and that may - Leone demo and I
hope it happens I'd be grateful as
certainly as well as the club because
what they'll do is they'll invest in the
community that's what we need
on Tyneside they've watched the abu
dhabi billions transforming manchester
city into league champions the many
believes Saudi Arabia have a similar
project in mind I think the club will be
able to invest significantly more funds
in players in terms of both transfer
fees and recruitment I think that's the
criticism which has been leveled at Mike
Ashley during his period of ownership of
the club with football on pause and
attention focused elsewhere
one of the most criticized States on
earth could be about to take over a
Premier League club English football
might be selling a precious slice of its
integrity Martha Kellner
Sky News